love
you you're talking about your early days
of uh
being a little bit alone and finding a
connection with the world through
being a journalist where does love come
into that
i guess finding for the first time um
some friends
it's very you know simple story some
friends that all of a sudden we
i guess we're the same you know the same
at the same place with our lives um
we're 25 26 i guess
and um somehow remember and we just got
really close and somehow remember this
one day
where um one day and you know in summer
that we just
stayed out um outdoors the whole night
and just talked and
for some unknown reason i just felt for
the first time that someone could
you know see me for who i am and it just
felt extremely like extremely good
and you know we fell asleep outside and
just talking and
it was raining it was beautiful you know
sunrise and
it's really cheesy but um at the same
time we just became
friends in a way that i've never been
friends with anyone else
before and i do remember that before and
after that you sort of have this
unconditional family sort of
um and it gives you tons of power
it just basically gives you this uh
tremendous power to
do things in your life and to um
change positively you mean like on many
different levels
power because you could be yourself at
least you know that some
somewhere you can't be just yourself
like you don't need to pretend you don't
need to be
you know um great at work or tell some
story
or sell yourself in some way or another
and so we became this really close
friends and
um in a way
i started a company because he had a
startup and i felt like i kind of want
to start up too
i felt really cool i didn't know what
i'm gonna
what i would really do but i felt like i
kind of need a startup okay
so that's so that pulled you in to the
startup world
yeah and then
yeah and then this uh closest friend of
mine died we actually moved here to san
francisco together and then we went back
for a visa to moscow and
we lived together with roommates and we
came back and
um he got hit by a car right in front of
kremlin hannah
you know next to the river um and died
the same damage
mm-hmm so
and you've moved to america at that
point
at that point i was like what about him
what about roman him too he actually
moved first so i was always sort of
trying to do what he was doing so
i didn't like that he was already here
and i was still you know in moscow and
we weren't hanging out together all the
time so was he in san francisco
yeah we were roommates so he just
visited moscow for
we went back for for our visas we had to
get a stamp and our passport
for our work visas and the embassy was
taking a little longer so we stayed
there for a couple weeks
what happened how did you so how did he
uh how did he die um he was crossing the
street and the car was going really fast
and
way over the speed limit and just didn't
stop on the on the pedestrian cross
on the zebra and i just ran over him
when was this it wasn't 2015 on 28th of
november so it was
pretty long ago now um but at the time
you know i was 29 so for me it was
um the first kind of meaningful
death in my life um you know both sets
of
i had both sets of grandparents at the
time i didn't see anyone
so close die and death sort of existed
but as a concept
but definitely not is something that
would be you know
happening to us anytime soon and
specifically our friends because we were
you know we're still in our
20s or early 30s and it still still felt
like the whole life is you know
you could still dream about ridiculous
things different
um so that was it was just really
really abrupt i'd say what did it
feel like to uh to lose him like that
feeling of loss he talked about
the feeling of love having power what
what is the feeling of loss
if you like well in buddhism there's
this concept of samaya
where something really
like huge happens and then you can see
very clearly
um i think that that was it like
basically
something changed so changed me so much
in such a short period of time that
i could just see really really clearly
what mattered or what not
well i definitely saw that whatever i
was doing at work
didn't matter at all and some other
things and
um it was just this big realization what
it's this very very clear vision of what
life's about you still miss him today
maybe for sure for sure
it was just this constant i think it was
he was really important for for me and
for our friends
for many different reasons and um i
think one of them
being that we didn't just say goodbye to
him but we sort of said goodbye to our
youth in a way
it was like the end of an era and it's
on so many different levels
the end of moscow as we knew it the end
of
you know us living through our 20s and
kind of dreaming about the future
do you remember like last several
conversations
is there moments with him that stick out
that will kind of haunt you
and you're just when you think about him
yeah well his last year here in san
francisco was pretty depressed for
as his startup was not going really
anywhere
and he wanted to do something else he
wanted to do build
he played with toy with like played with
a bunch of ideas but
the last one he had was around um
building a startup around death
so having um he applied to y combinator
with a video that you know i had on my
computer
and it was all about you know disrupting
death thinking about new
symmetries uh more biologically
like things that could be better
biologically for
for humans and at this end
at the same time having those um digital
avatars these kind of
ai avatars that would store all the
memory about a person that he could
interact with
what year was this 2015. well right
before
his death it was like a couple months
before that he recorded that video
and so i found out my computer when um
it was in our living room
he never got in but um he was thinking
about a lot
somehow does it have the digital avatar
idea
yeah that's so interesting well he just
says well
that's in his head the fish has this
idea and he'll he talks about like i
want to rethink how people grieve and
how people
talk about death why was he interested
in this i
it maybe someone who's depressed yeah
is like naturally inclined thinking
about that
but i just felt you know this year in
san francisco we just had so much um
i was going through a hard time he was
going through a hard time and we were
definitely
i was trying to make him just happy
somehow to make him feel better
and it felt like you know this um i
don't know i just
felt like i was taking care of of him a
lot
and he almost started to feel better and
then
that happened and
i don't know i just felt i just felt
lonely again i guess and that was you
know coming back to san francisco in
december
our help you know helped organize the
funeral help help his parents
and i came back here and it was a really
lonely apartment a bunch of his clothes
everywhere
and christmas time and
i remember i had a board meeting with my
investors and i just couldn't talk about
like
i had to pretend everything's okay and
you know just working on this company
um yeah it was definitely very
very tough tough time
you